RICK: When I was younger guy, I
couldn't stand ro see a
a car go to the junkyard.
You know, I would rescue it--
MIKE WOLFE: Yeah.
RICK: --and put it away
somewhere, so someday, maybe
that I could do
something with it.
MIKE WOLFE: Stash it.
FRANK FRITZ: This guy has saved
everything from concept cars
to hot rods.
I mean, he has an
amazing collection.
RICK: I got something in
here I think you'd like.
It's something from the '30s.
MIKE WOLFE: OK.
RICK: It's a-- it's
an old carnival ride.
We've got to move
a lot of stuff.
It's like a '36 Packard.
It's way back in that
corner, in there.
MIKE WOLFE: All righty.
So I crawl over a pile.
[grunting] And I look down.
And I can just see the fender.
I mean, this thing is buried.
[interposing voices]
I see-- I can see the--
RICK: Way back in there.
MIKE WOLFE: I can see
the steering wheel.
RICK: Yeah, way back in there.
MIKE WOLFE: Yeah,
that is way back.
For what I can see,
this thing is sexy.
So it's a carnival piece.
This doesn't have any
pedal drive train in it.
A lot of these older
pedal cars are longer.
They're wider.
They're heavier.
They're overbuilt. And
a lot of these cars
ended up as carnival rides.
That's not unusual.
I mean, for me to
even mess around
with trying to get
this thing out,
I mean, what are
you thinking on it?
I'm looking $500 out of it.
It's got be worth that.
That'd be a neat piece.
MIKE WOLFE: 500 sounds
like it's doable.
So I start going for it,
start digging this thing out.
There's all this, like,
exercise equipment on top of it.
[sighing] All right.
You getting it?
MIKE WOLFE: So as soon
as I get it chest height,
I want to twist and
maneuver it over to Frank
and let him take some of
the weight of this thing.
[chuckling] Let me turn it over.
You're working, dude.
And I'm not complaining, man.
I mean, this is what
it's all about--
finding something
like this, pulling
it out, working hard for it,
and then reaping the benefits.
All right, let's see
what's going on here.
FRANK FRITZ: Grill's
pretty good shape.
MIKE WOLFE: From the front
grille to the back end
of the car, it's streamlined.
It's airflow.
It's beautiful.
FRANK FRITZ: Looks like you
need, like, a little piece
to hold it up, there.
MIKE WOLFE: It
shows its history.
It shows its age.
But it also shows this
thing was a carnival ride.
You know, it's got a heavy pan
welded to the bottom of it.
The drive-train is gone.
It's beat to hell.
It's still cool.
Where did you find it?
RICK: I got it in a
garage in Detroit.
I think the wheels
turned on it, too.
MIKE WOLFE: Yeah.
RICK: I think they do.
FRANK FRITZ: Yeah, they turned.
They got a swivel on them.
Whoa.
[laughter]
RICK: Well, you could just
back it in the garage,
that way you wouldn't see it.
It's cool, man.
The more you look at it,
the more character it's got.
I mean, look at the
weld back here, man.
It's really cool.
[banging metal]
There you go.
RICK: You just-- you just
raised the price on it.
FRANK FRITZ: He's just like
you, Rick, doing body work.
There, look at that.
Looks pretty good.
MIKE WOLFE: That's better
than it was, right?
The gauge of the metal is really
made to stand the test of time.
I mean, who knows?
Maybe it was made from the
steel the actual car was.
That's what it feels like.
RICK: What do you think?
500.
Let's do it.
We're doing it.
That'll give us some room
on the back end of it.
I think it's cool, man.
It's definitely from
the right time period.
It's got the look.
A lot of these older
pedal cars, when
you see them on the ground, they
don't look like a child's toy.
They look like a miniature
of the car itself.
It's rough, but it's so cool.
We put a little
bit of a scratch--
On your collection.
--in the situation, but--
That's OK.
--you know,
that's how it goes.
- That's OK.
- You got the back?
Let me straighten
the wheels out.
Yeah, I got the back.
MIKE WOLFE: Frank and I have
come across a lot of cars,
but not cars like we saw today.
Rick saw the importance,
the significance
of these bubble top cars.
He was a visionary,
and he saw all of that
before anyone else did.
So cool.
We did it.
FRANK FRITZ: Rick, those are
some amazing cars you got.
I wish I had the
crystal ball you had.
- Yeah?
- That stuff is awesome.
RICK: I'd love to
have the guys back.
I enjoyed the day with them.
Been a lot of fun.
You ever bust it out
and show it, let us know.
We might be in the area.
Come take a look at it.
We come by and
may take a cruise.
- OK, I will--
- No doubt.
Hey, I will do.
I have plenty of projects.
I just finished my last car that
I was building for a customer.
And now, it's time
for me to take
and do something for myself.
[honking]
Roll on, Rick!
Yeah, catch you later!
See you later!
[honking]